so now that we can assign the user in
all the way to the game service let's
sign them out as well now for the
purpose of this tutorial and you know to
help debugging I'm going to put this as
a button on the front page realistically
I don't think you'd want to do this sign
out you probably want to keep more like
hinted menu option somewhere my hunch is
it's going to be fairly uncommon for an
actual user to want to sign out from
play games once they've signed in you
know no one's going to say I'd really
like to stop urning achievement progress
now however it does make your life
easier for testing against both sort of
the signed in and signed out state so
let's do that I'm going to switch over
to my nib and quite possibly for the
reasons I just stated there is no
official artwork for Google+ sign out
button however I did include some with
the artwork zip file that we're going to
use so first things first I'm going to
add a button onto the screen here this
is going to be a custom button with no
text and I have a notice we have a whole
lot more images now that's thanks to the
Play game services bundle that we've
added to our project and here's our sign
out
and we're just going to keep this for
all of our state's
alright next let's open up our assistant
editor and I'm going to control drag to
add an ID outlet sorry iboutlet and
we're going to call this sign out button
and then let's say underneath my sign in
button was pressed method I will add a
sign out button was pressed method now
let's fill this out you might think gosh
you know since we signed in through GPP
sign-in you know we could sign out
through GPP sign-in and indeed there is
a sign out method however we're not
going to do that here and that's because
there is no equivalent finished with
auth handler for signing out and you'll
end up in this weird state where you'll
have signed out from your GPP sign-in
object but your GP g manager the google
play games manager has no idea that
you've signed out it still might try to
access the cache data and might try to
submit scores and achievements without
realizing until later that something is
wrong so we're not going to do this and
instead we're going to call gpg manager
shared instance sign out and this method
will do a number of things one the gpg
manager will talk to GPP sign-in shared
instance and call sign out on that in
addition it will clear out any cache
data that it's stored on behalf of the
user and perform some additional cleanup
tasks so this is really the right way to
sign out we can try this and see what
happens
whoops looks like my sign in button is
off screen or my sign out buttons off
screen and that's because i forgot to go
back in here and adjust my auto sizing
to make sure that it is anchored to the
bottom instead of the top sorry about
that and yes I suppose I should really
be starting to use auto layout and
constraints here I I just haven't gotten
used to it yet anyway without other way
let's run it there we go there's our
buttons so I'm already signed in as you
can see in our NS log and now I'm going
to sign out and actually nothing happens
but I am actually signed out because if
I sign in again it will take me back to
the OAuth 2 point 0 permission screen
because I have signed out the services
ok if you want to sign in again we are
going to double check and confirm rather
than sign you and silently which is the
right behavior so I'm going to go back
and click accept going to go back in and
it looks like I'm signed in again so
this is nice however your typical user
is not going to be able to look at their
console log to figure out whether
they're signed in or signed out so let's
add one more refinement which is hiding
or showing the appropriate buttons based
on your signed in status so I'm going to
stop this and we're going to go into my
intro view controller m file and let's
create another method I'm going to put
it up here called refresh interface
based on sign it because I like long
method names the first question we need
to ask ourselves is how do we know if
the user is signed in or not one way I
supposed to do it would be to set up a
instance variable and perhaps am I
finished with off handler I could set
this to true or yes and then the sign
now that I consented to know turns out
we can also get this information by
asking the gpg manager and the way you
do this is we create a little bull
signed in equals gpg manager shared
instance has authorizer and this is
essentially a way of asking is the user
signed in the engineer who has written
this method would like me to let you
know that technically it's really a
method that determines whether the
library sees an auth object associated
with this user it doesn't actually
confirm that this author object is valid
or not but for all intents and purposes
this is a good way to find out if the
user is signed in and then we can simply
hide or show buttons based on this so
we're going to call our self that
sign-in button will hide this if the
user signed in and our sign out button
we will not set to not user signed it in
addition let's change that label where
we tell the user to sign in probably
don't need to tell them that if they're
already signed in so if signed in self
dot sign in labeled text equals welcome
layer otherwise and this is where you
can tell them sign in for achievements
and leaderboards all right now we just
have to call this method at the
appropriate moments turns out there are
three places where we want to call this
method the first would be in finished
with auth after we've called sign in to
Google Play games it would also be
appropriate to put this at the end of
our sign into Google Play games method
either one works next we're going to
want to do it on sign out was pressed
remember that signing out does not hit
our finish with auth error handler so
we'll also want to make sure we call it
here
and then finally we do want to call it
in viewwillappear
this last call is nice to have in
something like this where you've got
your views inside a navigation
controller and maybe you're switching
back and forth between different views
when this view is ready to come up again
it's good to make sure that all the
interface elements are as they should be
based on user Steinem status so let's
try this now and this time we have a
little welcome player message the Sign
In button is hidden and the Sign Out
button is the only one that's available
if I click sign out nearly immediately
the Sign Out button goes away the Sign
In button is back I get back the prompt
again to sign in for leaderboards and
achievements I'm going to say yes I'm
going to accept and we're back so now
that this is done I can go back into my
nib file and I'm going to move my Sign
Out button right on top of my sign in
button since only one of them will ever
be visible at any time so there you go
we're now properly changing the look of
the interface depending on whether or
not the user has signed in to play games
so this is great there are a couple more
refinements that would like to make and
we'll handle those in the next lesson
stay tuned
haha